good afternoon and thank you for
attending the discovery and chemistry
session I'm Mike Willis directors
teaching services and I have the honor
of introducing our next speaker dr. Lisa
matt Burrell completed their
postdoctoral research at MIT working
with Professor Peter seeburger and
obtained a PhD in chemistry from UC
Berkeley working under the guidance of
Professor Carolyn bertozzi she's
currently serving as a vice president of
drug discovery at h-2a biomedicine in
Cambridge Massachusetts beckham
aquarelle is with us today to discuss
her work at h3 biomedicine and the Broad
Institute on the generation of sp3 rich
compound libraries through diversity
oriented synthesis approaches the
resultant libraries contain a structural
diversity that holds promise and
screening campaigns for identification
of clinically relevant molecules the
title of her talk is diversity oriented
synthesis for discovery of novel
therapeutics please join me in offering
her a warm
okay I try to figure out this is working
it's working all right okay it's working
hello welcome to my office everyone good
morning good afternoon wherever you may
be I'm going to be telling you today a
story about some work that took place
both at the Broad Institute as well as
currently an h3 biomedicine so we're
located here in Cambridge so we'll start
first with some work at the broad just
literally two blocks down the street
from where I'm sitting right now in my
office and then I'll move on to some
work at age three biomedicine so has a
privilege to work at the Broad Institute
about four years ago now from 2007 to
2011 and I work with a great team of
chemists some of whom are shown here in
this picture and we were working to
build a compound collection for
screaming at the road for various
disease indications including infectious
disease psychiatric disease and oncology
and as part of this work we created a
novel compound collection of about
100,000 compounds a lot of this work has
been published and I won't go into great
detail here so if you're interested in
learning any more about the chemistry
I'd direct you to some of these
references so really our goal was to
create a compound screening collection
that had a great deal of skeletal
diversity which is obviously goal of
diversity Orion synthesis if you're
familiar with that approach but we also
wanted to make sure we access their
chemical diversity as well so for each
and every skeleton you see here as well
as others not shown we use synthetic
methods to create all possible
stereoisomers of a given scaffold and we
did this because we're interested to see
the importance of stereochemistry with
respect to biological
tivity thought it would give us an
advantage when following up on hits
resulting from screening efforts and I
have some examples of that for you in
this presentation so this is this
planning strategy we utilize to access
this your chemical diversity and
skeletal diversity is called a build
couple pair strategy a phrase coined by
professor Stewart Schreiber around the
time we started working on building up
this compound collection so the first
synthetic pathway we invested in was
based on using the aldol reaction to
generate some stair chemically rich
building blocks so these gamma amino
acids you could access all four
stereoisomers using both the anti and
syn aldol reaction we coupled that than
to an amino acid derived alanine derives
you know alcohol to access eight start
isomers of this linear I mean template
following a Madrid uh ction we then
utilized during pairing strategies such
as ring-closing metathesis to generate
these fourteen membered macrocycles
including all 16 * isomers as well as we
zijn cycloaddition chemistry to generate
lijo selectively both the 14 and 15
trials we also use a nucleophilic
aromatic substitution to generate medium
sized rings so both eight and nine
membered rings as well as omen chemistry
to generate these by our own ring
systems of this particular macrocycle
hasn't been published at this point but
we generate all possible stereoisomers
of this library and we also use some
head to toe mackerel atomization
strategies to generate this motorcycle
shown here for all of the the scaffolds
that I'm describing here a general
approach was to build up the filth
skeletons using solution bases assists
on large-scale typically at least ten
gram quantities of scaffold was
generated we then went solid-phase
chemistry which all outline and a few
slides to build a further diversity and
of appended sugar city so you'll see for
all these skeletons we have these
handles such as a means or aryl bromides
or acids which will then utilize to
generate on the large libraries as i
mentioned 100,000 compounds that were
generated so when our next big campaign
for generating libraries we decide to
utilize readily available glide cows Moo
Cow and glad tell but the D and L forms
to generate these sea glycosides and so
we did this because we had booked
focused a lot of efforts on making
macrocycles in our previous campaign and
we wanted to switch gears and access
some fused ring systems very oxygen-rich
ring systems so here as a former
carbohydrate chemist I was attracted to
glide houses of starting material and
the team utilized this carbon Ferriero
reaction to intentionally access one to
a mixture of isomers as we found on when
we're exploring this chemistry that we
could easily isolate the two alpha alpha
beta mixture by silica gel
chromatography so this chemistry enabled
us to access all eighths they're isomers
of this C glycoside on a fairly large
scale we could generally carry out this
reaction hundred gram scale and this
work has been published you know journal
of organic chemistry a few years ago now
we utilize this densely functionalized
of Tiran intermediate to then create a
different rating system so we generate
this fused azetidine ring system as well
as some radical cyclizations to make
this tricycle ikhwan ring system again
sna our chemistry to generate is another
tricycle green system with the medium
sized ring some apopse I'd opening
chemistry to generate this ring system
shown on the bottom left and again sna
our chemistry to generate a bridge
during system and most of these couples
but not all of them have been published
as well in Jo see
a third large campaign was focused on
utilizing chemistry to access small
nitrogen-rich heterocycles so this is
editing ring system we were attracted to
we were able to generate all eight star
isomers of the scaffold shown in the
center of the slide I had a number of
handles for then doing a very sparing
reactions to generate braking systems as
well as nah no hito pepper Zenith
scaffolds shown on the bottom right hand
side some spiral signet ring systems
that we were inspired by some of the
recent work of Carrara at the time we
also utilize rings was metathesis to
make the medium-sized rings showing the
bottom left-hand of the slide and then
some Buckwald and our relation in
chemistry to make the tricyclic ring
system I should say a little go to
detail here part of the reason for
developing synthetic methods to make
these small nitrogen-rich ring systems
were was to create a sort of compounds
that would be suitable for screening for
cns indications so we did some why we're
designs who create molecules with lower
black and weights and we had
traditionally been focus on focusing on
for example in the macrocyclic series of
scaffolds so we applied some different
design principles to this set of
compounds and for purposes of screening
for CMS indications as I mentioned we
utilize solid-phase synthesis at the
time at the Broad Institute I think
although as you'll see at the h3 portion
of my talk we've moved on here to more
solution-based solution phase based
parallel synthesis methods but I still
believe that solid basis this is very
attractive approach for making pretty
large libraries of discrete compounds
technology we use at the food who's
utilizing these synthase lanterns
available from millet oaks a company in
Australia we introduce our own handle
that at the time wasn't commercially
available which required a silicon-based
linker
activate with true flick acid and
enabled us to load primary and secondary
alcohols onto this Lantern I should
mention that the lanterns can we tag
with radiofrequency tags which enables
sealed tracking library members
throughout the synthesis which is really
an attractive feature of working with
these lanterns much easier than dealing
with resin once we got onto the solid
phase and loader our scaffold so all 16
* isomers of 16 different batches of
lanterns we then typically utilize
pretty robust standard chemistry such as
a mean ASA lations sulfonamide tappings
sometimes some cross coupling lives as
well as a amine coupling so pretty easy
chemistry once we're on to the solid
phase since it is difficult of course to
monitor reactions on the solid phase you
have to sacrifice your your product to
see if their actual its completion so in
the pathway that shown as an example
here we created over 14,000 compounds
since we had all 16 s there are isomers
typically we targeted anywhere between
500 to 1,000 compounds per stereo isomer
of the fairly large libraries we didn't
do any purification of our library
members of the bread Institute we just a
very large lobby Lively's I'd be very
costly in terms of HPLC purification so
what we did was scream the library
collection and then do resume system
purification posts hit generation which
worked well for us so for screening
purposes we had about a seventy-five
percent cut off in terms of purity as
measured by hplc and we targeted about
ten milligrams of compounds at the end
of the day / / library member towards
the end of my time at bro so 2011 that
was the last year I was there we shifted
gears of exploring parallel solution
based business methods one reason we did
this as we thought it would be an
attractive way to
hold up macrocycles in a modular fashion
so here I show some chemistry that
really combines I'm going to be the
building blocks that we created using
the build couple pair strategies here so
i have this glycol derived app i ran the
wii couple have been to miss gamma amino
acid from the Aldo pathway so we have
forests are isomers cross with aches or
isomers we can create all 32 * isomers
of this fairly complex macrocycle and we
were able to do this utilizing
silicon-based reagents available from
Silla cycle which we also use here at
age 3 now so this map recycle is
generated using nucleophilic aromatic
substitution I should point out we're
developing the chemistry we really only
scoped out this chemistry on a select
number of stereoisomers and then just
created all the sphere isomers and
relied on hplc master up to hplc
purifications you get the purified
samples using this approach we're able
to swap out the amino acid component to
access different ring sizes so here we
were able to generate 14 15 and 16
membered rings from this pathway so we
created about just over 300 macrocycles
using this chemistry that are in the
room screening collection so um the boat
institute is part of the MLP MLP CN
screening a network that was created
initiated by the NIH 2005's around the
time i joined the broom 2007 we decided
to become part of this network so the
road was both the specialized chemistry
center as well as a comprehensive
screening center and as part of this
network you know we had the privilege of
exposing our screening selections do
many different types of assays and out
of this entire network MLP see on about
through and 75 probes have been
developed I direct you to this paper
and so if you're interested in reading
more about that effort both abroad and
another screening stores in this talk
before I move on to H the h3 portion of
my talk I wanted to just highlight two
areas to programs that came out of the
efforts as part of the MLP CN so two
probes derived from the dasa library i
just described we're particularly
fortunate to find us two hits in the
infectious disease areas so these dose
molecules have performed really well in
this area in general substantially two
examples here the first was the screen
about 8,000 compounds a diverse subset
of the hundred thousand compounds we
generated at the road they're screened
in this phenotypic assay for malaria and
we found a hit compound here those
fairly potent for a primary screening
hit so around 100 nano molar in both the
wild-type and a chlorine resistant
strain of malaria so this is an initial
hit and so if you recall using our build
couple pairs strategy which other
nativist macrocycle using wrinkles
metathesis we had all 16 stereoisomers
as the street entities that underwent
this screening and right here it means
it most pony so you can see one
particular Sarah isomers preferred among
all the others most of them are
completely inactive some activity in
this stereoisomer shown in L really the
difference between those two compounds
is this exocyclic methyl group here the
two carbons here so really that upstairs
and it doesn't seem to matter it so much
in this case the clearly stair chemistry
is important we had made all these two
isomers or if we've made them a mixture
would have been very challenging to fish
out that one activist their isomer so in
terms of compound optimization the group
found that swapping out the exocyclic so
that the primary amine oil sorry the
party
hall could be swapped to introduce his
tertiary amine to really improve
solubility which was one of the
challenges with the initial hit and so
this became the probe for this program
ml 238 and this this initiative really
enabled the screen we group the rest of
the the dose collection so since I've
left the road of the rest of the
collection 200,000 compounds heaven
screams and on where there are
additional chemo types now that are
under investigation for this malaria
effort so the second program I'd like to
highlight them still an ongoing area of
work at the broad focus on chagas
disease so in this case the for 100,000
member library who screamed another
phenotypic scream looking for molecules
that could potentially be used for the
treatment of chagas disease and in this
case I think what's interesting about
this work is if you can see this I
appreciate it might be kind of blurry on
your screen and it's a little bit leery
of mine all eight star isomers of this
eight membered ring were found to be
some like molar activity in this assay
with this particular combination of
building blocks but what was interesting
was the stair chemistry really played a
role in the microsomal stability as well
solubility of these hit compounds so
having the complete set of sterilizing
which really facilitates compound cartas
ation and optimization so even if there
is you know activity no culpable
activity amongst your isomers there
might be certain sir isomers that offer
advantages from other standpoints so in
this case the SS configuration most
favored heard in the portion of the
molecule I have highlighted in blue ok
so I'm going to switch gears now to work
that has gone on just down the street
here in Cambridge a company called h3
biomedicine so i should mention of
course the work at the road was done in
me chemical bio
platform and that is was headed by my
clearly as well as tua Treiber and the
company I'm going to be telling you
about now h3 biomedicine as a company
that was started by Stewart Schreiber as
well as Todd gollub also at the Broad
Institute so h3 biomedicine came into
being about just over four years ago now
since founded back in 2011 where our
focus on oncology and I submission
you're here in Cambridge our investor is
a sigh so we have a unique business
relationship with a size our parent
company they're located locally here in
Andover as well as the course in Japan
and at age three we have at this point
just over 80 employees working here okay
so i thought this publication and acs
central science was timely it caught my
eye and putting together a presentation
recently you know one of the main
focuses here at age 3 as well there are
other as most other oncology companies
of course is really taking advantage of
the worldwide investment and the
sequencing of the cancer genome so I
really think this presents this work
presents a unique opportunity for
chemists all over the world to you know
see how we can be involved in creating
aiding in the persist precision medicine
efforts so I like this phrase I didn't
point it precision precision chemistry
on by George church of Harvard so here
at h3 really we're combining our
expertise in cancer genomics we have a
large investment in part bioinformatics
platform to understand and make sense of
the cancer genome sequencing efforts
both to uncover new targets but we can
also utilize this information to which
provides great enough regularity in
pathways that we already know or mutated
so really that's a huge effort here
which is a talk in itself I'm going to
focus of course like chemistry since I
McKenna's but we're coupling these
efforts in cancer genomics with
synthetic chemistry here so we have a
great team of synthetic chemists here at
h3 as well as external collaborators of
course with ultimate goal of course to
create novel therapies for cancer so we
do not just employ diverse wearing
synthesis here at h3 in terms of the
chemical strategy but that is the title
of my talk and that's what I going to
focus on today but I want to make you
aware about some other efforts ongoing
at age three we have a large focus on
using natural products which I will
mention in the context of our splicing
program on the end of my talk we also do
a lot of work in the area of developing
covalent inhibitors in various programs
which hopefully you'll be able to hear
about a few years if we're successful we
also engage in fragment-based screening
and of course structure based design is
a party part of any project even if you
take a screening approach so you know we
really use various chemical strategies
to really go after our targets of
interest so the vials you really drives
the projects here at age three and maybe
as chemists to whatever is needed to
find chemical tools and hopefully
ultimately drugs for these targets okay
so here I wanted to introduce you how do
we think about diversity or antithesis
at age three fairly similar to have a
thought about the road but chose
introduce it in this portion my talk so
this shows here really you know our goal
is to generate compounds that mimic the
structure complexity of natural products
but that can be generated in fewer steps
then say 60 steps to generate something
like hella condren and a lot for example
so typically when we're designing our
static pathways we aim to generate
compounds in less than 10 steps and you
know you can see here these are three
compounds have actually made here at h3
so these are representative scaffold
members that I'm able to show you so
they're oxygen-rich early structurally
complex compared to some typical
commercial vendor libraries and so I
won't dwell on this interest slide
without exceeding flatland that I'm very
fond of these papers of course to clear
rereading this escape from flat into
paper the other day I think it really is
inspiring for the work we're doing here
you know our philosophy is to generate
scaffolds that are rich in terms of
facts of sp3 content as well as the
number of chiral centers rather than
just depending you know sp3 rich locks
onto scaffold so we really tried to
design now the scaffolds that are
architectural interesting and
reminiscent of natural products so the
publications I've shown here I would
direct you to have shown that there is
this increase in saturation is
correlated with improving clinical
success in the second publication gets
to some of the reasons for that
complexity you know is negatively
correlated with the promiscuity of
compounds so I encourage you to read
those be having somebody some related
literature in this area analyzing
compounds that chemists have made
another shirt as published in the
journal of medicinal chemistry analyzing
the compounds produced over the last 50
years the trend is observed that you
know over the last 10 to 15 years the
compounds have have shown as decreased
in structural complexity as measured by
fraction sp3 centers while drugs on the
other hand of sort of maintains a steady
number in terms of fraction of SP three
centers and I did a quick calculation
the currents more recently approved fda
fda drugs maintain that that trend so
natural products of course you know
various analyses that have done
internally and externally put their
average earning a fraction of SP three
centers around them point five so about
fifty percent in contrast to you know a
lot of a lot of commercial vendor
collections which are lower typically
around point three so here at age three
our goal is to create a public
collection for ourselves to use here at
age three as well as are to be springing
our parent company a thigh so we're
trying to generate skillfully diverse
libraries of course using concepts and
diverse rates
this limp restructure complexity so
typically greater than point three in
terms of fraction sp3 centers and
typically greater than 10 genic Center
as already mentioned we try to design
scaffold to be less than 10 synthetic
steps often they're inspired by natural
products or portions of natural products
these are small libraries I should
mention in contrast to the efforts the
bird is too we decided to use parallel
solution phase synthesis to target hi
typically 4890 six-membered libraries so
we utilize Maps direct and hplc
purification for all of our library
members and the reason we decided to do
this is to generate a lot of skeletal
diversity in our compound collection so
to contrast with the bird we had about a
hundred thousand compounds that comprise
about 30 different scaffolds not
including stereoisomers here's you'll
see we really just chosen to create
these smaller libraries so to date we've
generated over 25,000 compound that's
comprised about 250 different scaffolds
we shall all mention in a few slides so
we the magician to doing just purely
unbiased every city orient synthesis
that securely chemistry jour than we do
also design target focused libraries
when we know the particular target word
going after for example kinase biased
libraries where this a good amount of
structural information available we'll
use that for an advantage and designing
libraries kabras the unbiased libraries
I think our event advantageous for a lot
of the screens that we do over there
might not be structural information
available for the target of interest
more recently we've gotten a lot of our
focus has now directed towards hit
follow-up so every synthesis and SAR
exploration so naturally growing our
compound collection in that way of a
great structural biologist computational
chemist in house that can help us and
following up on our hits to improve the
potency of our compounds when structural
information is available so at this
point in time so we got started in the
lab pretty much exactly four years ago
now
and a team of about ten chemists
contributed to generating this compound
collection so very talented chemists
that I really enjoy working with they've
created as i mentioned greater than
25,000 compounds which represents over
250 different scaffolds as well as
multiple sterilizes / scaffold so a lot
of structural diversity there we
typically prioritize our scaffolds
through synthesis for diversity by
diversity analysis using structural
based fingerprints comparing our
compounds to the compounds we all have
available to screen internally so in
addition to our own h3 compounds we've
made created using the restore and
synthesis we also have a subset of a
sigh screening collection as well as
their natural products so when we do any
except hydrabad screen or h3 you test
both dis das collection as well as the a
size that energy products so we want to
make sure the compounds that we're
targeting you know add something in
terms of structural diversity you can
pitch what we already have about
twenty-five percent of the collection is
biased towards ecology targets so the
number of kinase focus libraries have
been generated as well as some compounds
that report on towards pre-mrna splicing
which I will introduce later in the top
in terms of infrastructure for library
services here really don't have a lot of
fancy animation or going after your
small libraries so the only automation
of it really rely on is T cans for
liquid handling and processes the
library members after the synthesis we
do mass directed purification as well
but really that the chemistry we design
such that you know it's not very
labor-intensive so we do you know 24
compounds at a time in these voting
blocks and often just in vials and then
the chemists rely on silica bounds
reagents for example as sold by solar
cycle to aid in the cleaning up the
reactions long way
but the final purification is done by
hplc the individual bench chemists do
all the library design themselves
utilizing some pipeline pilot protocols
developed here internally by my
colleague Lakshmi akela and so it's
really designed to be a very efficient
process that the chemist can have an
idea for library enumerate that library
which is of course contains thousands of
possible library members but really
doing a diversity ranking to generate
just the 96 compounds of interest for
synthesis so that's our general approach
we aim to target 5 to 20 MiG's of
compounds we apply eighty percent pure
cut off here internally for screening
and we can access about 384 compounds of
the really the bottleneck is the actual
producing and design of the chemist
depending on the overall project needs
of the company given our relationship
with a sigh we had a unique opportunity
to take advantage of one of the great
chemistry expertise at a size so I'm
sure most of this audience is familiar
with the really great work done how then
which is a analog of hundred so at eisai
you know there's a very impressive
collection of really complex fragments
that we have utilized for building
libraries here at h3 so this is just one
example of this is published we toast
retro services here at how luv'n review
utilized a lot of these oxygen-rich
fragments for generating libraries such
as knepper cycles and really just taking
these types of fragments and divert
isaac them directly in about thirty
percent of the h3 collection is derived
from a site intermediate so it's they're
really nice working relationship so you
know historically das has been
criticized for having very greasy and
high molecular compounds and you know
whenever I give a presentation I want to
make sure that people know that that is
not you know greasing us and high
molecular weight is not an property
inherent to dobbs molecules das is
really about generating Churchill
diversity in structural complexity and
to do that you can also
have good properties for a screening
collection which you of course wants if
you're trying to develop a drug so 85
the sides of our compounds are rula 5
compliance we do have fifteen percent
outliers but you know since we're
creating these virtual libraries which
is very easy to enumerate a library and
then apply these property cut-offs so
this gives you an idea the mean values
of our library collections so good
molecular weight and mod p oh wow also
at the same time achieving this higher
fraction of SP three centers and on
average about 27 x centers virtually
since this is you know industry topic
can't show you a ton of structures i
could really just give you a hint of
kind of what we're working on but it
would create is as I mentioned greater
than 25,000 compounds so a lot of
different scaffold diversity here the
example I think I lost one of the
structures on the bottom right but we've
created macrocycle spiral cyclic ring
systems and the hidden bridge system
that used to be there but I guess
disappeared so we've made about 3000
macrocycles 3000 spy recycling systems
creating 3000 British drink systems so
in this graph here is a principal
component analysis and the large green
dots represents metra cycles or the
bridge during systems inspire so
different systems so that gives you an
idea of some of the structures
containing our collection since I can't
show you all of them of course in terms
of shape diversity a popular method that
people apply for analyzing the shape of
compound flex and compound collections
is called principal moments of inertia
it's a very simple way of looking at the
shapes of your molecules comparing them
to rods your disk in this triangular
format you know and historically a lot
of commercial flexions and approved
drugs sort of makes the right of this
triangle very broad disk like we're
interested in accessing other types of
shapes as many other publications have
shown are accessible right by methods of
difference or a synthesis you can often
get these more spear likes
structures so in green here are shown
our macrocycles which tend to sort of
allow us to expand into this general
space as I mentioned in the introduction
we also work on vitamin P staying here
at age three and although the outset of
building up our compound collection we
didn't intentionally target fragments
set if you apply the rule of three to
our existing compound collection and
impose a material availability to
requirements of at least two milligrams
we reach about a thousand sp3 rich
fragments that are available for
screening so we also have access to the
ACE I fragment set so shown here in
green or the aged reset so its
complementary to the ACE I set in terms
of accessing you know so different ring
systems for bridgeheads number of Spyro
cyclic centers and more fragments with
Sturridge enik centers so we do finding
based screening internally as well as an
Eisai so this slide I'm going to kind of
switch gears to the screening of our
compound collection and what I can share
with you at this point so this is the
pipeline of h3 so we have a number of
targets that we're working on some of
which are focused in the splicing area
which I'd like to introduce you now so
that's pre a matar pre-mrna splicing so
working on most advanced program except
during one but we're also more early
stages working on a Saracen to which
I'll introduce to you next so splicing
um is actually very complex i wish my
biology colleague that's sitting outside
here right now become and explain this
to you very fascinating and i'll give
you my chemist explanation of it
spliceosome is a rather complex this is
complicated complex that of proteins
that facilitate the removal introns
prerna to guild mature mrna and recently
around the time h3 was founded in 2011
there were reports about mutations and
spliceosome and various cancers so in SF
from b1 which is a component of the
spliceosome as well as you to a f1 and
sr sub 2 which i mention later this
became an interesting area for us to
think about working on here at h3 and
ace i had some historical efforts in
this area which I'll mentioned in the
context of natural products so it really
made sense for us to move in this
direction giving of the focus of our
cancer genomic efforts here at age three
so as a general overview of our splicing
platform here at age three we're looking
at going after specific spices on
targets such as SF 31 and srs of two but
also indirectly going after difficult to
drug cancer genes for simple mo MCL line
which can be modulated via splicing and
directly so this is an area where
invested in both using our small
molecule screening collections natural
products as well as antibody drug
conjugates so if you take a look at the
known compounds that are spliceosome
inhibitors or split some modulators
you'll find they're very complex so many
of them are natural products they're
having some work done nice work done by
thomas webb on 22 myosin analogs of
spices satin so simplify with
cyclohexane here but sorry you can see
i'm a laser pointer um the spices that
in the iron one of the programs is
replaced with the cyclohexane so as just
a simple glance you can see that these
structures are fairly complicated so
high fraction sp3 centers a very
challenging chemistry associated with
developing these compounds into a drug
that's said we have been focused on
working on developing voices ohm
modulators assisting people and
legislators
based on the series and put it aligns so
this is some work it was published
recently where we completed a total
synthesis of 60 Ops II put in a line sub
direct you to the paper and organic
letters further details but I think one
of the coolest features of the synthetic
sequence was this selenium mediated
allylic oxidation of this more simple
Mac recycle so this is will allow the
team to generate no thousands of analogs
of platoon allied both using total total
synthesis routes as a little semi
synthesis and this has been a very
exciting program as a chemist to be part
of you know all those synthetic skills
that our chemist acquired going to grad
school so I could not go to waste
because they're working a pretty
challenging chemistry and I've done a
great job so we have this nice set of
natural product focus sorry natural
product based molecules that are known
to contract with the spliceosome but h
through are also looking to expand on
this chemical space to find new
scaffolds so that's where our compound
collection comes in so my colleagues
have developed an in vitro splicing
assay to find new modulator of splicing
that may or may not directly achieve
their effects by interacting sf3 go SF
to be one they might go after other
factors of the splices home so I see I'm
fruit of running low on time so I'll
kind of briefly take you through the end
of this presentation so my colleagues
have developed a high-throughput screen
to measure splicing so really adapted
methods in the literature that was
gel-based for looking first place
modulators to enable us to skip the RNA
extraction step and just do a direct
dilution with DMSO and then adaptive
384-well plate format for screening
purposes so we're looking here to
monitor the removal of the intron and
detecting this mRNA the splice learning
so here we recently recently completed a
screening of 15,000 of the compounds
with made here at age three that
comprises about 150 scaffolds in this
assay they were screen a single point
Felix single point fairly high
concentrations because we were looking
just to see what we can find here we
found about 218 compounds that I
represent about 12 different scaffolds
that repeated in four-point
dose-response wearest resynthesizer any
hits or under 40 micro molar in terms of
I see 15 about 33 scaffolds to rot sorry
compounds survived that next round and
number tested 11.2 response we chose
then to paratah our exercise hits that
were below 10 micro molar along with
other considerations of including
biochemical and cellular
characterization and at this point we
have one surviving scaffold from those
efforts that we've decided to prioritize
for further follow-up I should say we've
also screened the ACE I collection and
the natural product collection have
other series that we're working on as
well and just choosing to focus on the
ACE three set for this presentation so
the series that we ultimately decide to
prioritize interesting Lee came from
very small library only 200 member
library you might think that you need to
screen the millions of compounds to get
somewhere but we were lucky to find what
which was could maybe even be considered
a singleton because only one of the
compounds had reasonable activity around
two micromolar fairly good properties
just set the cutoff of 511 their weight
low log P but more complex than your
typical screening collections so point
five in terms of fraction of SP 3
content so the next thing we did was
then to recent Assizes hit of course
this is a racemic scaffold has one stair
genex center but it's racemic so we did
a separation of the an aunt of being a
traverse through crystallization really
an answer has reached about 90% E and
then tested the to Sara isomers the two
enantiomers and found that the activity
was really found
be responsible in one and aunt Roberta r
enantiomer was a major active component
of that racemic mixture so that was of
course good information to have moving
forward and optimizing its compounds so
the next step is to take this compound
to see does it compete with known SF 3b
modulators for binding so we did this
competition experiment with the code in
a line based a modulator of SF to be one
and found that in fact that hit that we
found from screening our synthetic das
collection does compete with this
natural product of little I for binding
to SS would be one which is exciting so
at this point we've synthesized over 300
analogues to date you know one of the
things that we're really trying to get a
cellular activity so the initial hit
compound this is the are an answer of
compound a unless sorry I can't sure its
structure did not have any cellular
activity although it competed with SN 3
binding it was also weak this newer
compound that would find that we found
has an improvement the templed
improvement and the in vitro splicing
activity in the biochemical assay also
showing finally some signs of activity
in cells and also competes with SS 3b
binding so moving in the right direction
this is still all very early on in our
efforts last we have two more slides I
think I'm going over here so we're not
reached in developing we've developed
the in vitro splicing assay to the for
general modulators of splicing we're
also doing a more directed screen
working on SR SF to I direct you
actually sensitive times talk about this
is really interesting paper I thought
looking at trying to understand you know
what some of these mutations and make
splicing factors can mean in terms of
the disease biology so in this case this
searing rich Syrian RJ which splicing
factor the authors found that this altar
is the binding to RNA so the Newton's is
a gain of function type of activity and
really it's a thought it was found to
miss regulate like hundreds of splicing
events so to be called if that this was
cute death by a thousand cuts so the
biology and Sarah's very intriguing and
I encourage you you're interested to
read further so to end here so we did
recently completed a biochemical assay
of our full set of the 21,000 compounds
that are plated for screening but just
over one percent hit rate so coming from
multiple scaffold series so I have along
the x-axis is different libraries sorted
by scalpel class and anything below
minus forty percent response is
considered a primary hit so we're in the
process of following up on these hits
and of course doing the counter screens
and screen against wild-type asaurus if
to to hopefully find any in selective
compound so that is rural end so a
present we really have been focusing on
the synthetic chemistry to build up our
compound collection but we arrived at a
very exciting time at age three where
our compounds are starting to see a lot
of different biology open RNA splicing
area of also on books and minuses and
other targets and so I hope I convinced
you that it's possible to achieve
structural complexity in your compound
collection I'm using current advances
that chemistry while also achieving July
properties for further compounds to
further advance them to ultimately
become therapeutics so with that I want
to thank this is I think a current list
of all of the employees at h3 on the
names highlighted Boulder the people who
contribute to the building of the
compound collection as well as the
development of these placing assays
which I briefly mentioned and I also
want to thank the road a group that I
had the pleasure of working with a few
years ago now so the platform itself as
I mentioned by by my full name Stewart
Shriver and a lot of people that
contributed to the building up of that
hundred thousand member collection of
now on gone on to other places and
perhaps some of you and the audience
here work with them now so with that
I'll take any questions and so that's a
few minutes for questions
thank you for spending time here
you